what can you tell us about the Lima
project its objective was to search for
advanced extraterrestrial life and the
commander was he was my father Sir
your father was experimenting with a
highly classified material that could
threaten our entire solar system we're
counting on you to find out what's
happening out there so this film
ad astra it is such a departure from
anything that you've done before and i
want to start by saying that there's a
line in the film where you say i do what
i do because of my dad who do you credit
for what you do as an actor and what you
do as a person because you have such a
heart for helping others I certainly
everything I've done on film I see my
dad I definitely see my dad and then
it's my mom my mom is very giving that
way so yeah it's good she's got a big
heart credit to the parents parents et
spoke with Brad on the red carpet at a
special screening for his upcoming space
thriller film ad astra which hits
theaters September 20th I remain fully
committed to the lawful completion of
the mission
if necessary I will destroy the project
in its entirety
Brad also talked about his spirituality
and why he loves Kanye West's Sunday
service how did that come about and the
people want to know who is your faith
Kardashian about nonsense well I will
not pick favorites but no I it was it
was I think he's doing something really
special there it's just if you're a
celebration of life and people and it's
it's it's really delightful it really is
this Brad on screen again it makes us
wonder and want to ask you which of your
films are favorites of your kids I don't
know I don't know I don't know
well there's most of them they can't see
yeah yeah yeah I couldn't say when you
want to introduce Dom be fun
[Music]